dernier jour sur cette Open de France de
golf 2022 avec du suspense ce dimanche
25 septembre plusieurs golfeurs
pouvaient prétendre à la victoire parmi
eux le danoises garde l'italien Guido
migliosi ou encore les français Paul
Barjon et Antoine Rosemère la partie de
livinois était très suivie par ses
supporters du Golfe de la Boulie à
Versailles à club dont il est la tête
d'affiche
avec un excellente amie de mon fils et
que j'aime partager avec lui tous ces
moments de stress et de et de
compétition avec lui il joue sur son
terrain presque il joue avec son public
c'est un peu plus compliqué mais j'y
crois pas de problème c'est un fou
Antoine il fera tout pour c'est le
meilleur joueur de la police c'est cool
qui il porte les couleurs en plus
aujourd'hui donc
regarde le supporter c'est un des
meilleurs joueurs de la Boulie en étant
pro donc c'est cool de suivre de
soutenir jusqu'à jusqu'au bout quoi et
en plus on en profite parce qu'on est
d'ici on est en France et comme on peut
pas le voir tout le temps bah c'est cool
de pouvoir le supporter et donner sa
force malgré le soutien indéfectible du
public et quelques fulgurances sur les
greens Antoine rosener n'est pas dans un
bon joueur il termine à la 11e place
avec une carte de 74 ce dimanche 25
septembre le jeu a été très bon
toute la semaine franchement il y a rien
à dire là-dessus je suis assez déçu de
ma dernière journée mais
je crois qu'il faut retenir beaucoup de
positif de cette semaine et puis j'ai
vécu voilà quelque chose de d'assez
unique donc voilà beaucoup de beaucoup
de positif à en tirer j'habite à 25
minutes d'ici la Boulie est à 10 minutes
d'ici donc forcément qui allait avoir
beaucoup de monde donc non c'était
c'était vraiment exceptionnel à vivre et
j'ai hâte de revivre des moments comme
ça l'autre français Paul bargeaud
termine lui a une très belle troisième
place des résultats positifs selon la
Fédération Française de Golf les essuie
et les neuf derniers trous donc ils ont
fait une très bonne partie
malheureusement Antoine a mis la balle
dans l'eau 16 après avoir fait un très
beau Birdy au 15 et Paul prend les trois
potes au 18 mais bon c'est ça reste je
pense une bonne semaine pour eux même si
je peux comprendre la déception par
rapport au dernier tour où il pouvait
légitimement avoir des attentes plus
élevées au bout du suspense c'est
finalement l'Italien guidomigliosi qui
remporte 700 4ème édition de l'Open de
France devant le Danois Rasmus
hocheguard le golfeur de 25 ans égale au
record du parcours avec un 62 c'est le
deuxième golfeur transalpin a remporté
le tournoi français
c'est un sentiment incroyable j'ai gagné
un trophée ici au golf national à Paris
le Golf National est un magnifique
parcours de golf avec des installations
incroyables c'est très important pour
moi alors
sur le prochain Open de France pour
défendre son trophée le rendez-vous
reviendra l'année prochaine sur les
Green du Golf National de 50 ans en
Yvelines